bonjour il y à 22 ans certains d'entre
vous n'étaient pas n'étaient pas nés je
suis rentré dans un centre de dépistage
anonyme et gratuit
suite à une rupture conjugale à une
rupture sentimentale j'avais envie de me
rassurer et de pouvoir savoir si
éventuellement dvi une prise de risque
alors j'ai rencontré un médecin qui
effectivement m'a rassuré en me disant
que a priori il y avait eu peu de il y
avait peu de risques
je pense qu'il pensait aussi que je
n'étais pas dans le dans le profil se
profile où apparemment il était déjà
lui-même danser dans ses préjugés
alors on a fait le test et puis une
semaine après je suis revenu je suis
revenu au centre de dépistage
il était 9 heures du matin les deux les
deux secrétaires il y avait deux
secrétaires qui m'attendait voilà avec
mon avec mon résultat et j'avais oublié
mon petit ticket où il y avait mon
numéro puisque c'était un centre un
centre de dépistage anonyme et alors
j'étais prête à retourner la retourner
chez moi pour aller chercher le ticket
est en fait le médecin qui était
derrière elle avait les bras croisés ils
m'attendaient il a dit non c'est bon je
connais le dossier
et là je me suis dit s'il connaît le
dossier c'est que le dossier doit être
un petit peu différent de ceux de ceux
des autres c'est ainsi que j'ai appris
ma séropositivité
alors quelques secondes qui ont suivi
après je l ai suivi dans le couloir je
suis rentré dans son cabinet on espère
on peut être que j'avais mal interprété
ce qu'il me disait
et puis il m'a confirmé je pense qu'il
était quelque part aussi mal à l'aise et
peut-être presque plus mal à l'aise que
moi il m'a confirmé qu'il y avait des
traces d'anticorps du vih dans le sang
je me rappelle très précisément de deux
moments malgré le fait que finalement
tout dans ma tête bourdonnais mes
oreilles que ma vision devenait troubles
il m'a dit ne vous inquiétez pas ça fait
maintenant on est plus en 87 on n'est
plus dans l'est
années 80 on est en 97 et des
médicaments viennent viennent d'arriver
mais mais moi je me voyais je me voyais
mourir je ne connaissais rien aux
voyages ne connaissez rien au sida si
donc ce que j'en attendais et je savais
que j'allais mourir et je me rappelle
aussi de quelque chose de précis il m'a
tendu une corbeille où il y avait des
préservatifs
il m'a dit bon la prochaine fois
prenez-en pour vos prochaines relations
sexuelles et moi je me disais mais je
vais mourir
et lui il me tend sa corbeille avec ces
préservatifs comme s'il me tendaient des
cacahuètes pour prendre l'apéro et
franchement à 9 heures ça me semblait
dépassée je vous parie faisait son
métier mais pour moi c'était vraiment
pas le moment alors on est allé faire le
deuxième test puisqu'il faut
effectivement un test de confirmation
général le premier ne se trompe pas trop
mais il fallait faire ce test
l'infirmière cette fois ci qui était la
même que celle qui avait fait mon
premier test a mis des gants elle a mis
des gants et je suis certaine absolument
certaine que la première fois une
semaine auparavant
quand elle m'a fait la première prise de
sang elle n'avait pas mis ses gants
alors qu'est ce qui avait changé
qu'est ce qui avait changé en une
semaine alors que une semaine auparavant
potentiellement puisque je venais dans
ce centre de dépistage je pouvais aussi
être séropositive
qu'est ce qui avait changé pour que l en
tant que professionnels de santé elle
met des gants la peur était rentré les
préjugés était là j'étais là même qu'une
semaine auparavant
mais tout d'un coup je représentais un
risque je représentais une éventuelle
source de contamination pour elle alors
qu'on pourrait imaginer que une semaine
auparavant c'était déjà le déjà le cas
alors évidemment comme je vous le disais
je me voyais je voyais mourir parce que
c'est ce que c'est l'image que j'avais
en tête à ce moment là alors sur ce
point j'ai eu tort puisque vous voyez je
suis toujours là et puis je prends
plaisir aussi à dire alors on sait pas
dans notre habitude mais je prend aussi
plaisir à dire que je vis je vieillis
avec le vih je pensais mourir à cause du
vih mais finalement je vieillis et j'en
suis vraiment très satisfaite
aujourd'hui j'ai 22 ans 20 ans
maintenant de vie aussi avec les
traitements parce qu'évidemment pour
vivre et pour vieillir avec le vih
il faut prendre ces traitements
quotidiennement alors j'ai eu des hauts
et des bas avec ses traitements
j'ai connu des périodes très difficiles
notamment pendant pendant deux ans avec
un traitement qui faisait en sorte que à
chaque fois que j'allais dans un endroit
que ce soit au niveau professionnel pour
des vacances dans ma famille n'importe
où
la première chose que je faisais c'était
de repérer les toilettes c'est pas très
sexy et très glamour c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire
mais mes intestins était tellement en
vrac à cause de ces traitements que
vraiment ma préoccupation principale
pendant deux ans était de savoir où
étaient les toilettes alors je savais en
même temps que que ces traitements il
avait de bons résultats
j'étais en forme en tout cas mon virus
était endormi c'était celle
effectivement des traitements mais
évidemment ma qualité de vie il a été
très très moyenne
et puis on a changé de traitement il ya
quelques temps
vion de deux ans mon médecin m'a dit bon
écoute on se tutoie parce qu'on se
connaît maintenant depuis toutes ces
années
mon médecin m'a dit écoute via un
nouveau traitement qui viendra qui vient
d'arriver et qui te permettra d'avoir
trois gâchée par jour 2 de pouvoir avoir
un seul un seul médicament une seule
prise par jour bon une offre pareille ça
se refuse pas alors je lui disais ok
banco allons-y bien en fait au bout d'un
mois
je suis devenu complètement insomniaque
ce traitement en fait qui était qui est
très prescrit aujourd'hui et qui est
extrêmement efficace
malheureusement un certain nombre de
personnes ne supportent pas j'en fais
partie donc effectivement au bout de
cinq jours on a au bout de cinq 5
semaines pardon on a arrêté ce
traitement parce que vraiment je ne
fermais plus l'oeil de la nuit
au sens strict du terme donc la vie avec
les traitements a eu ses hauts et ses
bas
mais ce n'est pas tant de ça dont je
voulais vous parler ce soir c'était
aussi aussi de parler de ses peurs
finalement je suis j'ai cru rentrer dans
le monde de la mort je suis rentré
surtout dans le monde de la peur des
préjugés et des discriminations
parce que si la science a progressé si
des progrès scientifiques absolument
incroyable en l'espace de trente ans de
on a découvert le virus ont été faits
malheureusement la société les
mentalités donc on peut progresser voire
on retourne un petit peu en arrière et
vous voyez dans les années 80
probablement ses hommes sont déjà morts
les militants de la lutte contre le sida
disait déjà à l'époque on veut de la
recherche
we need reasearch notre hysteria on ne
veut pas on ne veut pas de la d'hystérie
on ne veut pas de la peur on veut des
avancées scientifiques
on va avoir plus d'éléments alors
aujourd'hui dans le monde on et 37
millions environ de personnes vivant
avec le vih il ya des jeunes des vieux
des enfants des hommes des femmes des
hétérosexuels des homosexuels chacun a
sa vie sa vie et sa vue médical avec
avec le vih mais une chose qui nous
relient très fort malheureusement dans
toutes ces vies dans tout c'est de par
le monde que vous soyez à paris à
ouagadougou à bangkok
c'est ce sont les discriminations
auxquels il faut auxquels nous faisons
face et en tant que directrice de
sidaction
ces discriminations serge et je vis je
les ai vécus au quotidien et je sais
aussi le nombre de témoignages qui nous
arrive aussi à sidaction et qui sont
aujourd'hui absolument incroyable en
2019 prenons l'exemple d'un simple
rendez vous chez un dentiste
il ya quelques années tu es un gros
problème avec mes gencives grosse
douleur je saignais les gencives été
gonflé alors je suis allé voir un
dentiste et comme pour chaque rendez
vous avec aventis le premier rendez vous
avez dû faire ça parfois de votre côté
rampling petites fiches qui nous permet
d'avoir quelques qui donne permet
d'avoir de donner quelques éléments sur
son état de santé est entre autres il
est une question sur êtes-vous atteinte
d'une maladie infectieuse
donc honnêtement j'ai effectivement dit
que j'étais séropositive
la dentiste m'a reçu et m'a dit non mais
ça va mais pas de soucis vous savez ça
ça va passer je peux rien faire pour
vous et à l'époque je n'avais pas je
n'avais pas les armes pour lui répondre
et je me suis dit ah là peut-être
peut-être raison et donc je suis
ressorti de son cabinet et évidemment ce
n'est pas passé ce n'est pas passer tout
seul
la douleur empirait donc je suis allé
voir un autre dentiste et cet autre
dentiste qui m'a évidement fait remplir
la même fiche lui a pris soin de moi
il a fait un simple détartrage
et qui m'a permis évidemment de soulager
mes douleurs ils n'étaient pas plus
courageux qu'un autre il était juste
professionnel sans préjugés il a utilisé
les moyens de protection qui l'utilisent
avec tous ces patients des lunettes un
masque
il s'est occupé de moi parce qu'il
savait que le vih n'allez pas lui sauter
à la figure
on a d'autres exemples quand on vit avec
le vih parfois parfois très surprenants
vous savez vous qu'on ne peut pas qu'on
ne peut pas voyager ou séjourner partout
on le souhaiterait
si vous souhaitez résidé plus trois mois
et avoir un permis de travail dans
certains pays notamment singapour la
corée du sud certains pays du golfe la
russie également si vous souhaitez
travailler dans ces pays
ça devient très très compliqué si vous
êtes séropositif puisqu'on vous demande
de faire un test est en général vous
n'avez pas le la carte de séjour qui
vous permet de travailler dans ces pays
et puis on en parle un petit peu moins
mais vous avez peut-être connu ça si
vous avez voyagé au aux états unis il ya
quelques années
même en tant que touriste aux états unis
il ya quelques années encore vous deviez
répondre à un questionnaire on vous
demande et notamment si vous étiez
séropositifs et bien entendu si vous
étiez séropositifs on pouvait vous
délivrer ou pas mais plutôt pas une
autorisation d'entrée sur le séjour sur
deux sur le terrain américain ce qui
fait que pour l'anecdote dans les années
90 la première conférence sur le vih a
eu lieu à washington et une partie en
fait des conférenciers n'ont pas pu
venir à la conférence ce qui est quand
même un comble barak
barack obama à changer cette règle est
depuis quelques années on peut de
nouveau aller vers les etats unis sans
aucun problème est sacrée c'est peur
parce que j'ai de mon côté quand j'ai pu
voyager aux états unis pour des raisons
professionnelles
j'ai toujours refusé de donner mon
statut de dire à l'administration
américaine que j'étais séropositive
alors évidemment je cachais mes
médicaments partout où je pouvais y
compris dans les sous-vêtements pour
être sûr qu'à la douane s'est jamais
j'ai été fouillé on ne trouve pas mes
médicaments
et si je le faisais c'est parce qu'on
avait de nombreux exemples de militants
la lutte contre le sida qui s'était fait
refouler
parce qu'à un moment il avait été
fouillée qu'on avait vu leur traitement
ils ont fait demi tour
on est discriminée dans la vie mais on a
on est aussi et on l'a été jusqu'à peut
discriminer
à mort saviez vous que jusqu'en 2016 un
arrêté du code de santé publique
stipulait que les portes les personnes
porteuses du vih et du virus des
hépatites ne pouvait pas bénéficier de
soins funéraire c'est à dire que les
thanatopracteurs ne refuse refusait s'il
savait que le corps du défunt était
porteur du vih de faire ses soins
funéraire ses soins funéraire ce sont
évidemment des soins qui permettent de
veiller notamment et de maintenir le
corps et d'éviter la décomposition et de
faire en sorte que les familles puissent
faire leur deuil
éveiller leurs défunts cela était
interdit aux personnes séropositives
alors avec les militants de la lutte
contre le sida on s'est battu on s'est
battu pendant 15 ans auprès de plusieurs
gouvernements pour faire en sorte que le
vih ne figure plus dans la liste des
interdictions à recevoir des soins
funéraire et si on s'est battus c'est
pas juste parce qu'on avait envie d'être
embaumé quand on était une fois qu'on
était décédé c'est parce qu'ils ont
refusé qu'une loi existe et se base sur
des faits qui n'étaient pas prouvés
scientifiquement dans la littérature
scientifique aucun cas aucun cas de
transmission n'a eu lieu entre le corps
d'un défunt et un thanatopracteur
à partir du moment où les
thanatopracteurs comme les dentistes
utilise les moyens de protection qui les
utilisent pour tous les défunts les
thanatopracteurs font des soins
funéraire auprès de personnes dont ils
ne connaissent même pas le statut
combien d'entre vous aujourd'hui enfin
un test de dépistage
et si vous mourriez aujourd'hui comment
est-ce que le thanatopracteur pourrait
savoir si vous êtes séropositif ou pas
alors on a on a lutté ferme depuis 2016
à un arrêté a effectivement retiré le
vih de cette liste excluante mais on a
aujourd'hui encore des thanatopracteurs
pas tous heureusement parce que certains
sont soutenant c'est un autre acteur qui
nous disent si nous apprenons que le
défunt est séropositif nous utiliserons
notre droit de retrait et ça évidemment
en tant que associations de lutte contre
le sida on est extrêmement en veille
pour dénoncer ces cas si effectivement
c'était on s'apercevait que c'était le
cas alors on envie de dire mais jusqu'où
va-t-on aller on constate aujourd hui où
je vous disais que les personnes
vieillissent et avec le vih
qu'est ce qui se passe quand on vieillit
même sans le vih
on va dans les maisons de retraite on va
dans les ehpad et aujourd'hui on
commence à avoir des histoires des
témoignages de personnes qui nous disent
on a refusé que je partage les mêmes
couvert que les autres résidents même
couvert on a mis à part des personnes
nous ont dit que des aides soignantes
faisait des soins avec des gants des
toilettes avec des avec des gants qui
n'utilisaient pas avec d'autres avec
d'autres résidents
donc on se retrouve de nouveau sur c'est
sûr c'est sur ces faits incroyables qui
fait que comme je vous le disais si la
science à progresser les mentalités
elle ne progresse pas et au contraire
parfois parfois recul mais ce que je
peux vous dire aujourd'hui c'est que il
ne faut pas avoir peur de nous n'ayez
pas peur de nous mon virus ne va pas
vous sautez à la tête
vous pouvez me touchez vous pouvez
m'embrasser vous même transféré avec moi
vous pouvez partager vos couverts vous
pouvez aller aux toilettes après moi
vous n'avez aucun risque aucun risque
d'être contaminé notamment parce que je
connais mon statut que je suis je suis
séropositif je connais mon statut et je
suis sous traitement et ses traitements
dans les progrès scientifiques ce qu'on
a découvert c'est que non seulement ils
étaient bons pour la santé des personnes
qui les maintenait en bonne santé mais
en plus ils avaient un effet préventif
et donc je peux aussi vous dire
aujourd'hui que si vous avez une
relation sexuelle avec moi même sans
utiliser de préservatif même sans
utiliser de préservatif vous n'avez
aucun risque d'être contaminé mais
qu'est ce que je vous raconte là qu'est
ce que je vous raconte là je vous assure
que jamais jamais jamais je ne pourrais
vous dire quelque chose comme ça sans
avoir une preuve scientifique et cette
preuve scientifique elle existe on en
avait entendu parler récemment dans les
journaux elle est basée sur une étude
qui s'appelle partner qui a eu lieu dans
14 pays européens depuis 2010 1700
couples sérodifférents dont l'un des
partenaires est séropositif sous
traitement efficace ces couples ont été
suivis et pendant huit ans ces personnes
qui n'utilisent pas de préservatif pour
leur apport aucun cas de transmission
n'a eu lieu
aucun donc aujourd'hui la science a
prouvé qu'une personnes séropositives
sous traitement sous traitement efficace
à risque 00 00
il n'y a aucun risque est là et le fait
de faire l'amour avec une personne
séropositive qui connaît son traitement
qui connaît son statut et c'est pour
cela que j'insiste là dessus c'est pour
ça qu'on insiste sur le fait d'aller
vers le dépistage est de connaître son
statut
parce que aujourd'hui en étant sous
traitement il n'y a aucun risque de
transmission
alors bien sûr quand je vous dis que
malgré ces résultats malgré ces avancées
scientifiques
le doute persiste on a un autre exemple
de chaque année et encore cette année
sidaction a fait un sondage auprès des
jeunes et des moins jeunes pour
percevoir les prises de risques
notamment mais aussi pour poser cette
question
on a posé la question de se dire est-ce
que vous accepteriez d'avoir une
relation sexuelle avec une personne
séropositive en utilisant un préservatif
devinez 25 % des répondants ont dit non
non je refuserais je refuserai d'avoir
une relation sexuelle avec une personne
séropositive en eux mêmes en utilisant
un préservatif
et pourtant ces personnes connaissent
l'efficacité du préservatif mais la peur
des préjugés rendu impossible l'idée
même de pouvoir avoir cette relation
sexuelle je ne vous dis pas qu'il ya 23
ans 24 ans j'aurais peut-être moi aussi
répondu non peut-être que moi aussi
j'aurais été dans mes propres préjugés
et c'est pour cette raison qu'il est
extrêmement important fondamental que
les personnes séropositives puisse
témoigner et témoigner encore et encore
et sortir de l'invisibilité
parce que c'est cette invisibilité qui
alimente les préjugés est ce que
voudrait pour finir vous montrer c'est
lui je sais pas si vous connaissez c'est
magic johnson un basketteur américain
c'est l'un des premiers qui a montré qui
a parlé publiquement de sa
séropositivité et c'est lui qui m'a
donné envie et l'espoir de vivre parce
que effectivement aujourd'hui c'est
grâce à des gens comme ça et grâce à
d'autres qui témoigne qu'on peut
continuer à diffuser ce message d'espoir
ce message d'espoir voyez comme il est
beau et on envie de dire aujourd'hui au
revoir le stigma bye bye stigma elle la
gorge parce qu'on est beau parce qu'on
est belle on est belle et on est fiers
et n'oubliez pas n'oubliez pas parce que
aujourd'hui en france il ya 6000
personnes qui découvrent leur
séropositivité par an et parmi ces 6000
personnes
il ya beaucoup de jeunes ici mais parmi
ces 6000 personnes il ya 22 % de
personnes de plus de 50 ans alors vous
pied de jeunes protégés vous dites aussi
à vos parents de se protéger
n'oubliez pas parce que tout le monde
est concerné et puis protégez vous
prenez du plaisir
prenez ces primo nous prenez soin de
vous et surtout n'ayez pas peur
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]